does Marquez Brownlee
like Android or iOS
better personally
I have two phones right I carry this
Android phone in my right pocket and I
carry the iPhone in my left pocket and
my main sim card with the phone number
that I use the most
is in the Android phone but I have the
iPhone because there's so many things I
have to be familiar with both worlds but
there's so many things that are just a
little bit better on the iPhone I have
family group chats and facetimes and all
that but there's also camera stuff
there's some apps that are iPhone only
my phone key is on my iPhone so it's I'm
I've split my time like for real but I I
do prefer if I could only use one
I would just have the Android phone